Tradutor: Maurício Kakuei Tanaka
Revisor: Maricene Crus
Mark Twain é um cara.
Não sei nem a cara dele,
mas, uma vez, falei a frase
que vou falar agora,
e acharam que ela fosse minha.
Eu me senti péssimo por isso.
Mas esse cara
falou que tem dois dias importantes
de verdade na nossa vida.
Um dia é aquele dia em que a gente nasce
O cara nasceu, o cara existe.
E tem um outro dia que é,
talvez, mais importante ainda,
que é o dia em que a gente descobre
por que diabos a gente nasceu.
Então, essa frase não é minha, e agora
que eu já pedi desculpas para o universo,
eu começo, porque...
Eu pensei: "Cara, por que
diabos eu nasci?"
E eu nasci para virar músico.
Eu sou um cara muito de humanas,
mas não sei por que
essa separação tão absurda assim
que as pessoas fazem
entre humanas, exatas,
sendo que, tipo assim, apesar de
a música ser uma matéria muito humana,
ela vem,
pelo menos pra mim,
a inspiração vem muito de uma ciência
exata que assusta e afugenta as pessoas,
que é a física.
Resumindo:
os cientistas estavam lá,
sendo cientistas, de jaleco,
com aquela parabólica em cima da cabeça,
e eles pensaram assim:
"O que diabos mantém
todas essas galáxias?"
Não estou vendo nenhuma.
"O que diabos mantém todas essas galáxias
unidas, coesas, maravilhosas?"
Newton já tinha respondido isso:
que era a gravidade.
No entanto, eles foram calcular:
mas tem que ter uma força muito extrema
para manter todas essas galáxias juntas,
e somente a gravidade não é capaz
de manter tudo isso junto.
E aí, eles: "A gente não sabe
o que é que mantém tudo junto".
No entanto, vamos dar o nome
a isso de matéria escura,
porque a gente pode detectar
a força que ela tem,
e essa força que ela tem
é seis vezes maior
do que a força da gravidade.
No nosso universo, tem
seis vezes mais essa matéria escura,
essa coisa que a gente não consegue ver,
mas que é responsável por a gente existir.
Tem seis vezes mais isso do que as coisas
que a gente vê, eu, você, esse estádio.
Então, que diabos é isso?
Para mim, a música...
Quando a gente ouve
só uma canção no rádio,
ela pode ser só três minutos de um cara
falando qualquer coisa sobre a vida dele.
Mas, por trás daquilo, daqueles três
minutos, daqueles cinco minutos,
tem uma vida inteira.
É saindo na rua,
indo atrás de vivências, experiências,
e é, como foi falado aqui, minutos atrás,
mergulhando e se mostrando por completo
e transformando vida em música,
que a gente vê que aqueles três minutos
de música, às vezes, são muito mais:
são, às vezes, histórias
de vidas inteiras.
Fiz uma palestra, mas,
na verdade, eu vim pra tocar.
Então, vou tocar uma música pra vocês.
(Violão)
♪ A casa cheia ♪
♪ O coração vazio ♪
♪ Escorre do meu rosto ♪
♪ Um lamento arredio ♪
♪ O veneno acabou ♪
♪ A festa esvaziou ♪
♪ E o tempo da inocência ♪
♪ Terminou ♪
♪ Os amigos que eu fiz ♪
♪ E que jamais voltou ♪
♪ Ferida que eu abri ♪
♪ E é que jamais fechou ♪
♪ Para passar a luz ♪
♪ Que vence a escuridão ♪
♪ Para eu tentar aquecer ♪
♪ Meu coração ♪
♪ Vou tentar derrubar ♪
♪ Que é para me ver crescer ♪
♪ E às vezes me matar ♪
♪ Que é para eu renascer ♪
♪ Como uma supernova ♪
♪ Que atravessa o ar ♪
♪ Eu sou a maré viva ♪
♪ Se entrar vai se afogar ♪
♪ Eu grito pro universo ♪
♪ O meu nome e o seu ♪
♪ E ele vai me escutar ♪
(Violão)
♪ Eu mandei um sinal ♪
♪ Rumo ao firmamento ♪
♪ Eu forneci a prova cabal ♪
♪ Desse meu desalento ♪
♪ A sonda vai voar ♪
♪ Até não dar mais para ver ♪
♪ Levando o que há de bom em mim ♪
♪ Levando pra você ♪
♪ E os que não estão mais aqui ♪
♪ Todos os que se foram ♪
♪ Eles vão me encontrar ♪
♪ Em outra dimensão ♪
♪ Onde não existe dor ♪
♪ Não se declara guerra ♪
♪ Quando estamos em paz ♪
♪ Vou tentar derrubar ♪
♪ Que é para me ver crescer ♪
♪ E às vezes me matar ♪
♪ Que para eu renascer ♪
♪ Como uma supernova ♪
♪ Que atravessa o ar ♪
♪ Eu sou maré viva ♪
♪ Se entrar vai se afogar ♪
♪ Eu grito pro universo ♪
♪ O meu nome e o seu ♪
♪ Ele vai me escutar ♪
Boa noite.
Obrigado.
(Aplausos) (Vivas)